[Musique]
ce vendredi 17 août cyril melchior
président du département s'est rendu à
saint pierre pour signer un protocole
d'accord avec jérôme conti président de
l'ue recopa dans les locaux de la ceta
société d'exploitation de techniques
agroalimentaires un partenariat visant à
permettre l'installation sur un terrain
départemental situé au port d'une
plateforme logistique de conditionnement
du stockage et des distributions matheux
raboté à nouveau un nouvel outil
industriel de la logistique digne de ce
nom dessus un endroit stratégique la
zone ouest et ça nous permettra nous de
continuer à porter le développement des
filières agroalimentaires via nos
filières animales et végétales
parce qu'il faut pas oublier coup on est
représentant des paysans qui sont les
propriétés du groupe de copains à
travers cette signature de convention de
ce matin mais que le président de l'ua
cua pas le département a voulu s'engager
dans le soutien à toute la filière des
fruits et légumes de la réunion vous
savez que nous avons en somme le
développement agricole de l'île et ceux
qui produisent dont les incultes et les
paysans doivent écouler leur production
et bien plus encore pas à travers tous
les outils qui ont été développées sur
le territoire de la réunion notamment
ici à saint pierre ne comparent récupère
ses produits les transforme et bien sûr
les écoles auprès de la population de la
réunion
une visite des installations de la ceta
unité de traitement de fruits locaux et
de conditionnement de jus de fruits a
suivi la signature cheminement c'est
qu'on travaille que les producteurs
locaux ont réceptionné puis on les
presse et on les met en bouteille
la délégation s'est ensuite rendue dans
les locaux de la cilam en compagnie
laitière des mascarets le site qui va
nous permettre en fait de traiter les
éleveurs réunionnais et on va y
retrouver diverses familles de produits
laitiers qui vont être fabriqués
ça peut aller du yaourt au lait en
brique fromage glace et puis aussi on a
d'activité jure le trio si nous avons un
maître fromager ici à la réunion à saint
pierre un jeune réunionnais qui a suivi
donc nouvelle formation
et aujourd'hui je suis aussi
impressionné par toutes les chaînes de
traitement de voir que le lait qui est
produit dans les prairies de la réunion
pour nos exploitants arrive ici est
transformé et que cela on le retrouve
sous différentes formes mais aussi à
travers les différents fromages produits
par la cie dans la matinée s'est achevée
chez vivea qui regroupe 150 producteurs
de fruits et légumes sur toute la
réunion une filiale de leur combat tout
comme la ceta et la cilam
[Musique]